this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
if you are a female and have certain
problems with your reproductive organs
your doctor may recommend a robotic
hysterectomy to remove your uterus
your reproductive organs include your
vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
you may need a robotic hysterectomy if
you have one of the following diseases
or conditions
heavy or constant uterine bleeding
anemia and pelvic pain
cancer in your uterus
cervix
or ovaries
non-cancerous fibroid tumors in your
uterus
or slipping and sagging of your uterus
into your vagina due to weak or injured
pelvic muscles and uterine ligaments
before your procedure an intravenous
line or iv will be started
you may be given antibiotics through the
iv to decrease your chance of infection
you'll be given general anesthesia
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and down your throat
to help you breathe during the operation
your surgeon will make a small incision
near your belly button and insert a
plastic tube called a port
carbon dioxide gas will be pumped into
your abdomen through this port
the gas will inflate your abdomen giving
your surgeon more room to see and move
the surgical tools
after your abdomen is inflated a high
definition camera will be inserted into
this port
your surgeon will make additional port
incisions for robotic instruments as
well as instruments used by patient side
assistance
an assistant will insert all of the
robotic tools through these ports
unlike standard laparoscopic instruments
these tools can rotate 360 degrees and
have more flexibility than the human
wrist
seated at a special console
your surgeon will operate the robotic
arms and the camera with joystick like
controls and foot pedals
a computer will translate the exact
movements of your surgeon's fingers into
precise movements of the surgical tools
at the same time a high definition
vision system will provide a magnified
three-dimensional stereoscopic view of
the surgical area
depending on your condition you may have
a partial hysterectomy in which your
surgeon will remove your uterus
but leave your cervix fallopian tubes
and ovaries in place
if you have a total hysterectomy your
surgeon will remove your cervix
along with your uterus
if you have a radical hysterectomy your
surgeon may also remove your fallopian
tubes
ovaries
the upper part of your vagina
as well as nearby tissue such as your
pelvic lymph nodes
at the end of your procedure the tiny
incisions will be closed with stitches
staples surgical glue or closure tape
dressings
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring
you will be given pain medication as
needed
you may continue to receive antibiotics
through your iv
you may be released from the hospital
the same day or within one day after the
procedure